foreign
North Carolina one of those beautiful
places in the country what's up Bradley
hey Dr John how you doing today great
man how are you
I'm doing good what's up uh well so my
question is my I have five kids
and they are at my mom's for the summer
just hanging out doing summer fun things
with them
and uh thank you my wife and I we are
considering selling our current home and
buying a new home while they're gone
because it'd be easier to move with no
kids in the way of moving but is it
weird to
like then go pick up the kids and just
come back and be like hey here's our new
house like should we have a conversation
with the kids like through FaceTime or I
mean they're eight and under so most of
them
in my mind like won't even really be you
know they're easily adjustable but then
again at the same time like I could see
that being a big deal for kids you have
five kids eight and under
yeah yeah they're all about 18 months
apart
I bet your house is so so incredibly
still right now is it amazing it is it's
awkwardly still like I'm used to a quiet
being something is getting destroyed and
now it's just peace and it
it's weird are they at your parents
house
yeah yeah my mom
is your mom and dad just like snorting
Xanax off the bathroom counter how are
they doing this and that's
I don't know they're they they uh
they're Troopers for sure I could just
see your mom being like well your dad
started smoking again and no that hey
that's that's great
um how far away is your parents house
how far away are they from you guys uh
12 hours oh so they're in Mississippi oh
wait man you have a how old's your
youngest
uh two that two-year-old is not going to
see y'all for the whole summer
uh well so we we plan a Midway visit to
basically to kind of uh you know hang
out and for a few days okay and uh so I
yeah it's we're testing now this is the
first summer we're we're trying it okay
uh it wouldn't surprise me if that
two-year-old or that I guess there's a
four-year-old if a two and four-year-old
end up needing to come home halfway
through maybe right um that wouldn't
surprise me that that's a lot a lot of
separation from Mom and Dad for a two
and a four year old
it is just developmentally that's a lot
but uh maybe with their brothers and
sisters eight six and five I mean even
five that's that's a long time but all
I'd say that's not even why you called
so if I find myself in your situation so
you're thinking about selling the house
y'all live in it'd be so much it's
easier to do everything just is just
going to the bathroom is so so much
easier
um having breakfast is so much easier
but you're thinking about selling your
house and moving to a whole new place
but
especially you know I mean the housing
market is crazy but uh
my wife was looking at home values and
realized that like basically for the
price for the value of ours we could
there's like new developments in new
neighborhoods growing up that have much
more you know playgrounds and things
like that is that we could uh
potentially give
you be in a better situation more rooms
for the same price so I could you know
uh as we currently are in where we're in
like a 1960s home where at any point you
know something could really go wrong uh
we could end up being in a newer one
with the same money basically yeah I
mean and and new things are going to go
wrong in I mean in new houses too so
what I what I want you to do is to if
y'all decide to move great I don't want
you to create a bunch of problems where
you live now
I'd much rather you see some opportunity
somewhere else
yeah right
um because your house
I I'm I'm convinced that the house
you're in right now you could raise all
all five of these kids and you and your
wife and it would be tight and be
maniacal and you'd be loud and all those
things but y'all could do it you're
seeing some new developments that have
some cool amenities that you guys want
as your family that might make your life
more fun or a little bit easier or
whatever no
that's all well and good so if you were
to sell your house and let's pretend it
sold in 30 days and you were gonna move
and let's pretend in August August 1st
is your move date and you're out of here
and
um your two-year-old and your
four-year-old have come back home
um
here's what I would do in that situation
I would have a place picked out that I'm
I could put an offer in this is going to
be our home I would not say hey we're
thinking about moving this or that or
that or this or anything like that
I would say we found a place and here's
why those kids that young the ambiguity
the you instantly pull the tether out it
doesn't make sense whereas you and your
wife like hey we should look at some
houses that can become fun and that can
become an adventure for a kid it can be
unsettling
but okay you guys you guys find a place
here's where we're gonna go
then you take pictures of where their
bedrooms will be and what we're going to
move um it's a it's it's PSJA and it's
old we're gonna move into very concrete
this is going to be your room what color
would you like it to be red or orange
orange or pink
that way they get the
concreteness we are moving to a new
house hey look here's a picture of the
pool here's a picture of the playground
here are some things that are going to
be very real in our lives and
you get some ownership in this move
however small it might be
and by giving them some ownership they
are have a vested interest they move I
Can't Describe but then they move into
that choice and that decision and when
they walk in that sense of this is all
new and this is all kind of freaky is
also I picked that color that's mine
and this is my room or this is our like
if you're sharing rooms this is our room
and we picked this and maybe you asked
doing a baseball poster or a Hello Kitty
post I don't know what your kids are
into but find one or two little little
variables that they get a choice in all
the way down to your maybe even your
four-year-old but for sure your your
eight-year-old I guess you have a six
you have a seven or something like that
five-year-old something like that yeah
yeah eight six
five three two okay yes you're eight and
you're six and your five-year-old I
would sit them down separately than the
other two
and say we're gonna have a big kid
conversation we found an amazing new
house that's gonna give more space
that's gonna be by a new park and a pool
and they're gonna go wow and then one or
two of those kids if not all of them
will go but I like our old house and
what about my room and that's when you
can say check this out and you can have
an iPad for them or even put on a big
screen TV and say this is going to be
your room and you get to pick between
baseball or football or whatever and
like whatever and whatever and you get
to pick this color which one do you want
and just go through it that way and that
way when they show up it's more of a
sense of ownership and not a sense of
they pulled the wool out from under me
the worst thing you could do was just
drive home and pick them up and be like
new house and then they will never feel
settled for the rest of their life
that's not true they would be fine but
um I definitely wouldn't do that but I
would I would bring them into it when
you have some some security this is
where we're moving this is the house and
when they can have tiny little bits of
ownership
um I think that's that's awesome
okay yeah thanks I appreciate it you
know the older ones were my main concern
and then uh
yeah who knows we might get to getting
everything house ready and then decide
hey we still really like this house but
I had a um I had a a professor a
counseling Professor her name's Aretha
marbley she's just
um really important person in my life
she gave me some advice when my wife got
pregnant with Josephine
um six years after we had Hank and she
said you can avoid all of the problems
that having at the first kid experiences
with your second kid if you will just do
one thing and I rolled my eyes I was
like whatever everybody's giving me all
this stupid parenting advice and she
said just from this point forward start
referring to your wife's pregnancy as
his baby
just his baby
and what I didn't understand
developmentally at the time
um was he was very very young but he was
so desperate kids are so desperate for
any shred of ownership
and his parents we can't give them a lot
of ownership and we're there's some kind
of weird cultural Zeitgeist where it's
like we they do we tell us and we tell
them that's terrible parenting but if we
teach them little bits of hey here's
what ownership looks like and feels like
and you get to pick this
and if one of them throws a temper
tantrum I don't want to move I hate this
that's fine you just took like there you
move their house on them that's cool
when you're ready to come back and have
this conversation we'll be happy to I'm
sorry that you're choosing to throw a
temper tantrum over a really neat thing
but I do understand that this is scary
for you so when you're ready to choose
what room color you want come on back we
can't wait for you to be here and I'm
gonna let them go have their little fit
and go do the little thing I I'm not
gonna get affected by that I'm gonna do
what's best for my family right
um but man you give them a little bit of
ownership whether it comes to having a
brother sister you give them a little
ownership into
um their appearance and how the room
looks or little bits of ownership uh man
goes to such a long long way with with
um childhood development so well done
man
I don't know how y'all pulled the scam
of the century sending all five of those
kids away but well done well done and um
best of luck to you man if you do get a
new house send us a picture and we'll
post it up here man can't wait